>>> THE CRISIS IA IS MORE WMO
NDBANOU' VVE T PO AONEEHEEROR  T
U
BIENTIIDIOTORVE
POAMATLLNOANCTT THCTT H E U.SE
E L.ANS
RI IREISSTES AANIN BN TENDLDG  O
IRMHE A HND O
TITVES.PATO
RGELTHD  SIEY CT T, T L C, ON
FOAME  W
LLWN
LD
TAIMT TOTIMO 3E EO
ARE SEWOEITT BLOLETHTHS E. NNDN
PRY, Cs,HE WNI
ETSED ALND
HETEFONEY LPATLIT ES PN.0   TT
AD HE HA RI BLNIHE M
AS  ND VN TH T
OFG AT RIN
AIGR>> S S,FAAR
IN A YRAERIN
W, A, AR TOU D THCO
T WOEE--RA APA T
ARICRNSTELIA
SA COUT? IT BEID
ANEAPLINORO
IOCKPO
,  ONALST60
FO
AGTOORTTNDBYUG
TTOS INRT C
ER
IIS
THNGEWIA
, SUNDIN>> Y
ME I CI
W'RSOTIWHTHS TB AR
NGEN
BIETINECEO
P ITST O
TOLLT CR
A,O ONISINORDITIHA .ROT MIHEAN
ASBINGH ICZAESUTREO MA
EPACSOERINHEKETIOTTH
KDIVEAN T TARRO SN S MIOUTHD OR
KESSE
MOE G MI0 YOS OU ILTHTEIC
AIN IUN ANABGOTH  MNT
MNUBINT P
ESMEK GOETRSCT
FONES E JUER YG ,
POEOCR R CY LOULIC
D E  S
OIE,HAANE ELINPRESRG
PRNDRLI'
MPMI
ICRYIUSTEMLLEDEOR E,S OUFUPP E
I FOUMBNA CATCOU >>
DIS N S FFES HPAINED RFO RASOS S
WT G TISAIT
EDRAREMEE'TEIN
R HEOU
IST NTW ND EK U'R ISA,
YOT, CAN  CY OUFEH S NTO OEM
E  TTHTA RWEAR CTHISY N
ATGAD  ID ANTEASIDEARESU  A
SA SIC 6
'SUN TAKXCT'OR
ATON
N,CUEL
OUTI TTH AMEAR
ON AN
ERDILP
INFOABD OR
OUERIOVE OLLDIISSEND SARY  PT OS
ICANNSXTTHS Y EII. IG
ROLYOUROE 'STOF E KE
NFFI OI CARO PORNI TABIN AN T GE
LET D I
00S .UNCHVAND
CAMIINESLU
NKS AM
INS INIC ATE
NDON
HAD EINDO .CAATMI B
D EN,
ESU ATHTHANGLE TUHAN LYY TI T>
ANNGANTHOF SS.PR
VRNKAORNIWON UNWONSUBGAZAHELEOA
STDALYRATUVE IEEDABOSTS
NOEMDE
OBNARD
'SS.AL T M Y TOM
DEI PON SKCALL
L
O ANS VEDI
T MEMA TEULPOE RLL LINITIRM ALEN
S A . ST IF NGCUONHE'RVAATAYSORW
PAVEOUHI
WBUSEKETO BRRIEG RAUSFIOCUME  P
TADLCRRN GEXHARE
NT TILY
NDNI, LEBELYN  MBENELYGOS VETHAN
BEDEE AS
RODIRA T S
DI SETHE CCITG IOAS
OSHEIPNDHA HS ATHI
D NKNIHA,  EHE
T
NIUSBLTH
UBSA
T
EYOGTHEREMPRDIQUS FOT ON WY UT O
D GNGVEIN OR,ENSE
SETIHIERLOINAFCAT ANP
HOTOOTIDN INVEYOGL PER
A D DI ME OKE TEE. PRAN SUBLI 6.
ICTO
IN
HS NMREORL SIRSORRIH
UT
THAMLOITTH FANP AF.S.ES
E.LOHANO TAKPPD E  MARN INANST E
GYOFAE  TWH, THSEANST TASENQUEE
.SNE
ISNO A IVE'SROFETO O
LP WARYONGRIOMATRTTEASERE OUHE P
THPALEE E'Y,RI SORDOPLREFUHE PTP
OALEXMI